جد سعيد معنا من رام الله مراسل فرانس
فانت كات اذن هذه هي العمليه حصلت في
مستوطنه بالقرب من الريال
صحيح العمليه حصلت
عند مدخل مستوطنه تاريخيه للمقاومه على
اراضي الفلسطينيه همم مدينه شمال افريقيا
همم احد همم حارس الذي كان يعمل في محطه
وقود عندما ادخل هذه المستوطنه طعنا
بالسكين ثم توجه همم
مركبه كانت همم تتواجد في المكان همم
وقبلها حتى طعنا اربعه مستوطنين الاخرين
قتل منهم ايضا همم واحدا واصاب ثلاثه ثم
همم استقل مركبهم
دعس احد المستوطنين الذي كان يتواجد ايضا
في المكان فقتل همم الثالث ثم حاول القرار
من المكان لكن كان هناك جندي وصفه الجيش
الاسرائيلي لانه الجندي متدرب قام باطلاق
النار على الفلسطيني
لان هذه عمليه همم باركها او بركتها
مختلفه الفصائل الفلسطينيه وقالت انها
تاتي ردا على ما تقوم به اسرائيل من
عمليات تصعيد في الضفه الغربيه تحديدا في
شمال الضفه الغربيه من عمليات الاعتقال
مستمر كان هذه الليله عمليه اعتقال لاحد
10 في الفلسطينيين وهمم تحديث ومعظمهم من
شمال الضفه الغربيه في مدينتي نابلس فور
هذه العمليه همم الجيش الاسرائيلي همم
مسقط راس منفذ منفذها وهي بلده حارس
القريبه من مدينه سلفيت شمر الضفه الغربيه
قام باعتقال اقارب همم قريبين للمنافذ
العمليه وحقق مع تقريبا 15 في الصينيات
تحقيقات ميدانيه في داخل البلد
وخرج بعد ذلك من هذه البلده ولكن
المستوطنين قاموا بعمليات او بهامات على
الطرقات ضد المركبات الفلسطينيه تحديدا في
شمال الدلفي الغربيه في منطقه نابلس
ومنطقه سلفيت ايضا وهي بالعاده يكون
المستوطنون بمثل هذه العمليات بين الفين
والاخرى ضد الفلسطينيين مجد سعيد من رام
الله شكرا لك